[موسيقى]
ايه طبعا هو عمل جهد جبار جدا في كتابه
بحث فرنسي كتب كتابه باللغه الفرنسيه انا
قريت كتابه باللغه الانجليزيه والعربيه
الكتاب جدا ممتاز
ولما قالت الترجمه العربيه اصدمت من
جودتها بامانه
والصحاويين خلقت حاله التعاطف في الكتاب
القارئ يشوفها همم حاله تعاطف وكانه النمش
معهم طبعا مو مطلوب بدها ان هي دين بس همم
حاله التعامل المطلوب
[موسيقى]
كتب
التوبي ورقه نشرها في المركز فيها الان
مركز الشرق الاوسط سنه 2010 عن حزب الله
الحجاز
تقرا الورقه من اولها لاخرها هو يتكلم عن
حزب الله الحجاز على هامش منظمه الثوره
الاسلاميه
فؤاد ابراهيم اخذ شويه من المعارضين
السابقين اللي رجعوا الى المملكه واستقروا
لان هم جماعه المفاتيحين
[موسيقى]